Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and during my
Seeing Red video I asked you all to submit
questions about the rest of the season and
the big WTF reveals.
So I picked 10 of them to answer in this video
with one bonus question.
Also if you’re finding me for the first
time, just because this season of Arrow has
been so awesome, I’m doing a special series
of bonus videos counting down to the finale.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
They post each Wednesday before the episodes
air.
Feel free to leave me suggestions for those
in the comments.
So let’s talk some Connor Hawke and Deathstroke,
careful for spoilers for everything through
episode 20 if you’re not caught up.
Here we go, Question 1 - Rose Lily asks Will
Oliver tell Thea that he is the green arrow
now?
I think that person he tells in the trailer
for the next episode is Thea.
It could be a misdirect, because Thea talks
about being sick of all the lies and we know
that Merlyn is back, so she could just be
talking to Merlyn in that scene and Oliver
could be talking to someone else.
But I think Thea will know the truth by the
finale.
I mean everyone else in Oliver’s family
seems to know at this point.
And Quentin is the only main-character besides
her that doesn’t know.
So Oliver is either telling him or Thea.
Question 2 - Tim asks Do you think Roy will
be fixed or healed before the Season Finale?
Yes, I think all of the Mirakuru drama with
the army of super soldiers will be over by
then.
In the episode description for streets of
fire, episode 22, it mentions Caitlin Snow
making a big breakthrough at STAR Labs.
So they probably get the cure in that episode
and use it, but that won’t be the end of
it.
I think in the finale Slade’s army will
be gone and it will just be Team Arrow VS
Team Deathstroke.
Just the core main characters this season.
I think the big theme this season or at least
the second half of the season, is Full Circle.
So think back to where Oliver and Slade started.
They were on the island.
Gradually new characters came in and eventually
we got all the new Team Arrow people, Slade
has his team and his army.
Now a bunch of them are going to go away or
die.
So these last couple of episodes we’re traveling
back to the beginning.
So the final moments will be just like things
were when everything started on the island.
Just Oliver and Slade.
I’m also saying that the final moments of
the finale, will probably take place on the
island.
Question 3 - The PTMD3 asks Who's Connor Hawke?
I’m going to just take from recent comic
book history but Connor Hawke is the son of
Oliver Queen and Sandra Hawke.
In the new 52 comics he’s the Red Arrow.
So everyone is expecting this new kid of Oliver’s
to turn out to be Connor.
They could be doing something different on
the show and Gender Bend the character.
I think that it would be wasting too much
of an opportunity for them to just make the
child a normal non-comic book character.
But even if it is Connor, that doesn’t mean
Oliver’s going to train him right away.
I mean in the timeline of the show he’s
about 6 or 7.
So basically this child, we’re hoping is
the implied heir of the Green Arrow legacy,
someday, when Oliver dies or retires.
This child will take up the Mantle.
Just like some of the Robin’s in the Batman
comics have taken up the mantle of the Bat
when Bruce Wayne goes away for a long period
of time.
Question 4 - Manuel Cortez asks Is Oliver's
son the next person who has to die according
to Slade or will he live and Oliver will train
him?
Otherwise why bring that issue to the show?﻿
There’s a couple of reasons they could be
dumping this info on us now.
First off, I definitely think the child will
figure into the finale.
Otherwise they would have waited to introduce
him in the season 3 cliffhanger.
That doesn’t mean Slade will try to kill
him.
But he’s defnitely done his homework on
Oliver.
So I think he knows about the child and will
hang him, so to speak, over Oliver’s head.
That could either be like Slade doing that
same pick who dies moment using Felicity and
Oliver’s Son.
Or he could just straight up kidnap him and
take him to the island to raise as his own.
We have to end up back on the island some
how, so someone is getting kidnapped either
way.
Question 5 - Monika Pain asks what was Moira
going to say about Malcolm before Slade attacked
them?
She was just going to tell them he’s still
alive.
Merlyn really just said that he wanted Thea,
he wanted his daughter to be with him.
So I think he’s going to offer to take her
away.
If he has a secret plan involving Thea, they
show hasn’t revealed it yet.
He’s not coming back till episode 22.
So whatever is happening between Daddy and
Daughter will go down then.
Question 6 - Laxus Dreyar asks Do you think
Oliver or Thea will take up Moira’s run
for Mayor?
They could totally do the Oliver Queen as
Mayor story from the comics.
It would be an interesting wrinkle in whatever
the big story of season 3 is.
Mayor and daddy by day, vigilante by night.
I think I’d rather see Diggle or someone
else be mayor, but I wouldn’t be surprised
if Oliver takes the job.
I don’t think anyone expects Brother Blood
to make it to Season 3 still being mayor.
I think Laurel will totally kill him in the
finale.
Question 7 - Sergio asks who's worse at keeping
their secret identity a secret, Oliver Queen/Arrow
or Bruce Wayne/Batman?﻿
Definitely Oliver, like I said: Pretty much
his whole family except for Thea found out.
Barry knows, everyone at ARGUS and some of
his biggest enemies like Merlyn and Slade.
Brother Blood doesn’t know, which I think
tells you just how important his character
is.
As in he’s not that important.
Batman’s identity has been found out by
a few villains and super smart characters,
but generally it’s really really rare.
Question 8 - Bobby asks what is your thoughts
about them creating a new shared DC Universe
with the movies and tv shows?
What do you think they should include in that?
So David Goyer said something recently, he’s
mostly known for writing comics and he’s
the one writing the Superman VS Batman movie.
He said that Warner Brothers, who owns all
the movie rights and they own DC Comics, isn’t
quite ready for a unified system like Marvel.
Not enough of the right people in charge are
on board with the idea.
The problem is, you just have an army of producers
and writers who all want to do their own thing.
And in order to do a shared movie and tv universe
it has to be a priority for everyone from
the top down.
When they do get that figured out I think
it should be just like Marvel’s version.
All the studio and netflix movies and tv shows
should exist in the same universe.
And let the comics and the animated shows
exist separately.
Question 9 - Brad Gilbert asks Does killing
Moira give Merlyn andTeam Arrow a reason to
unite?
Definitely, but I think the real thing that
will convince Merlyn to fight with Oliver
will be Thea asking him to help.
Asking him as her father.
Like she says I’ll let you be a part of
my life if you help my friends and family
defeat Slade.
So for Merlyn I think it will be more of a
temporary truce with Team Arrow.
He doesn’t hate Oliver, but as Stephen Amell
once said: “They have unfinished business”.
He was talking mostly about Tommy and the
Undertaking from season 1.
Question 10 - Dansky Games asks do you, think
that the last person that slade said has to
die is Himself?
I think that’s a really important thing
to consider.
I don’t know the whole plot of the finale
or anything.
But I think it would a really awesome twist,
if Slade during the process of the finale.
Starts to realize what he’s done and is
just so overcome with greif that he asks Oliver
to Kill Him and end it all.
In that situation, killing him would be like
an act of mercy.
So I don’t think Oliver will do it, he’ll
prevent Slade from dying or killing himself,
so he has to live with all the bad things
he’s done since taking the mirakuru.
Bonus Question - Red Arrow asks do you think
that Oliver’s child and the mother will
be featured on The Flash show this fall?﻿
Yes, but only in episodes that invoke people
from Arrow.
I don’t expect the Flash to cast them as
regulars.
I think we’ll only see them when Oliver
visits the Flash show or when the Flash show
crosses over with Arrow.
That doesn’t include being mentioned.
I think Oliver and Team Arrow will talk about
his kid a lot and we just won’t see them.
Like they’ve been talking a lot about Barry,
but we haven’t actually seen him since episode
9.
So thank you so much for submitting questions,
this was a lot of fun as always.
Only three more episodes to go, so be sure
to subscribe to get all my videos.
My next bonus video will post on Wednesday
before episode 21 airs.
Feel free to leave me suggestions for what
to put in it.
Right now click here for my Top 10 team arrow
moments this season and click here for my
episode 20 review.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!